but first reading writing and radicalism
that's the focus of tonight's angle
[Music]
all right let me just say as a mother
it is a minefield for parents out there
now too often the very people whom
you're supposed to be able to trust to
teach your sons and daughters are the
ones you can trust the least
like this lovely teacher a woman named
amber parker who was just fired from
franklin high school in el paso texas
come on forget math and science her
message to students recently was don't
be mean to pedophiles
we're going to call them maps no minor
attractive persons so don't judge people
just because they want to have sex with
a five-year-old
if you wonder why your kids come home
questioning your family's values and
beliefs
it's because of so-called educators like
ms parker
now in that push to normalize deviancy
she's doing her part to advance the
left's larger goal which is to persecute
anyone with traditional views on
sexuality
now the unions and the leftists who fund
them want conservative parents driven
underground or out of public life
altogether
bottom line if you're a devout christian
a muslim or a jew
then they think you're hateful and they
want to convince your kids to hate you
in new jersey second graders are now
being forced to learn about gender
identity starting this semester new
guidelines include discussing the range
of ways that people express their gender
and how gender role stereotypes may
limit behavior huh
of course when parents object to that as
most normal parents should they're
attacked by unions as dangerous
extremists when extremists start
attacking our schools to drive a wedge
between us we take it personally people
who only want to fight and argue to
score political points should take that
somewhere else
take it somewhere else okay translation
you people who pay the bills should sit
down and shut up or move out of state
so much for diversity equity and
inclusion all these people stand for is
exclusion
republicans in new jersey are smartly
jumping on the state's new education
standards that push this gender identity
issue into the classroom but despite
parents strenuous objections democrat
governor phil murphy
greenlit this new sexualized education
standards that are being implemented as
i said right now
so in new jersey's seventh district
interesting stuff happening there tom
king jr republican is trying to unseat
incumbent democrat tom malinkowski
hitting his both inflationary record and
the radicalization of the school
curricula issue
gender identity and education as young
as first grade exposure to pornography
as young as second grade parents
rightfully were angry at these standards
and stood up across new jersey
republicans and democrats alike to make
sure that their kids have the education
core curriculum education that they
deserve
and they need virginia governor glenn
younkin he was just on with me last week
on set he won remember last november in
large part due to this issue
and republicans across america need to
remember how crucial parent power is at
the polls
and that means in states like wisconsin
where they start sexualizing their kids
in school very early
recommended reading for a gender
expansive preschool curricula
include jacob's new dress my princess
boy and julian is a mermaid yay
in michigan one education official is
pushing the notion that a child can
question his or her gender while still
potty training
kids have a sense of their gender
identity between the ages of three and
five so about the time that kids have
language they can start to share with us
whether they're a boy or a girl um
usually those are the only things that
they will identify as because those are
the only options we've given them
and in idaho
idaho mothers and fathers were shocked
this week to discover the state's
department of health and welfare is
implementing a sex ed curriculum
endorsed by planned parenthood
and the training materials for this
comes from a left-wing group with an
innocuous name called education training
and research or etr
and that promotes what they call the
queering of education and normalizing
the consumption of pornography check out
one of the instructional videos for
teaching porn literacy
critical thinking skills are the largest
component of porn literacy it's the
ability for young people to analyze and
ask questions about the media that
they're viewing porn is meant to
sexually excite a viewer and create
fantasy
right
oh my god
and it gets worse they advocate cartoon
porn
wow that's so big
i never knew it could be so huge
hey jane what are you looking at
and of course then there's the handy
tips to students about how to hide their
porn viewing habits from parents
is that part of the normal experience
too
i find that when i normalize watching
porn and being curious students are a
lot more engaged in the conversation but
they are also building trust with me
it's okay if they have watched porn and
it's okay if they had thought about porn
i always make sure to say someone being
curious about sex and or porn does not
make them a bad person it makes them
human
special thanks to the idaho freedom
foundation and the center for american
education for publishing these videos
and exposing what's happening in idaho
schools
so over the years right under parents
noses these deviant organizations
burrowed into our culture and into our
schools
they vacuum up multi-million dollar
contracts to flood our schools with the
values that are directly at odds with
what most parents are teaching their
children at home
but this is applauded by the teachers
unions and approved by liberal school
board members and democrat legislators
and governors the goal of america's
education establishment it's not to
prepare your children to be productive
citizens is to propagandize to them to
be left-wing activists
the old norms god family and country
they haven't been just kicked to the
schoolhouse curb
they have been labeled as extremist and
even fascist by democrats and their
allies
but parents
especially moms
i'm here to tell you tonight that i'm
with you in this fight all the way
we need to be warriors to protect the
innocence of our children that means
demanding that the schools that we fund
with our tax dollars teach what we know
our children need to know math science
reading writing
not whatever sexual trend is in fashion
at the moment not abortion not climate
change activism not racial grievance
this election in november it's not just
a referendum on the economy and crime
obviously those are critically important
but also on the democrats domination of
our schools
it's up to us to stop these menaces from
damaging our children
enough is enough and that's the angle
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else